yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Dino Dino Dino chess is the
right pronunciation who's that suriname
that's goodish he's gonna hit your
channel interesting okay so um we've
gotten this is a good line for black six
okay well I can't decide this I do like
actually this is okay okay there is an
idea now to take and play d4 something
that I always found extremely strange
but has been played by lots of good
players I came as we get something
different Eagles to h5 to let's see what
happens here the usual scenario here is
that white gets us four against three
majority on the King side and down Black
has to be careful not to get into
trouble against this night h4 h5 can
also be an idea quite often black now
feel tempted to take not him ok I can
try to go to h4 here or g4 night each
form not entirely certain about that
give it's a good idea right now
and maybe just not each for immediately
hmm not something i'm expected what is
the night doing they're trying to take
and put something on d3 here maybe okay
I can take on this is one thing I can do
what we should should choose five of the
puzzle and it should explain that I'm
kind of a little bit slow here with all
those normal moves somehow maybe maybe
you can check up on there with h6
giveaway d5 and it looks a little bit
uncomfortable for black I was resonant
inside here just winning a piece maybe
maybe it's got h6 but I'm not quite sure
what he's supposed to do now I mean
taking is definitely helping me yeah
we'll see
see what happens he's taking some time
as well
hmm fallacy really from Australia that
must be what kind of time with different
is that why it's in the evening their
problem okay so he did take at the end
interesting move that's a good solution
actually that's a good solution problem
length okay look team one isn't great
because this is hanging by the way it
could still be an idea but he's got 94th
everything else fails now if he's on
that square very good move 96 Wow not
good
very unhappy about all this before is
extremely weak air and the dark squares
don't don't look good especially my goji
form before it's like looks terrible
when it I wonder if maybe night a form
192 they're probably should call 92 94
the very decentralizing move maybe 90 to
cover deform gathered that was that was
very good you're taking a 96 I'd
completely i defused any any sort of
ideas that I had and black is just fine
now very fine
[Music]
so yeah we are down to two minutes both
of us I don't have anything right here I
can just stay I mean you can take and
playbook the age that would be a simple
oh yeah this is still better for him
even though it does not feel like the
most critical continuation at least
first glance you would assume that there
was maybe something better wearable I'm
getting a game on the if alien he's got
this that this Bishop is just a better
piece it always put some pressure on f2
and yeah I can basically just stay here
and wait the only thing that I'm
currently thinking of is I can I could
try like f 4g 4g five year and a very
good day that might work if it but okay
so well here i can put the bishop on the
c4 if he allows me to do that not sure
if you will probably not okay I can I
can do this definitely
so yeah I would like to put the bishop
on f 150 for you can I can try a bishop
at once before yeah okay well now I have
to do this very well doesn't want to
trade which is understandable in some
way but also see threatening we should
have to hear my might be hind morning
yeah I think I think I can still do it
and g4 is a little bit yourself but ok
let's fight yeah I mean that this is
probably objectively sad but I want to
try to find you in this position we
should be sighs no checkmate I think I
don't see it at least it's got a couple
of checks but I'm not mated
whoa
okay oh that's absolutely right Quinn g3
going to chicken like that Wow damn very
nice Jay didn't see an alternator check
should i won okay check check check
black forfeit on time and Wow boom yeah
i was extremely lucky at the end there
ain't no no time at all yeah I was it
was a gamble relate to that there r I T
I mean here was not absolutely sure but
I think I should not lose if I just
defend passively that tried some stuff
here that was maybe not not cold for the
engine is on equal which which i think
is probably correct is basically I mean
I don't think that this was so great
because now we cannot use as majority
and i think it was better to to have
this option to track b5 and get a person
I just stay I think I'm okay really
improve piedras possible am and I was
trying stuff here by the way if he takes
everything it takes here this is no
problem at all i think i am just drawing
fairly straightforwardly because
the dawn co-leader valued this is better
and what he did and this is probably
just too risky and he he found us yeah
we should have to I was already here
possible which I did not see here it was
even more in stronger right here he'd
black went immediately yeah I didn't see
that I mean I didn't see that g4 fails
immediately did we just felt extremely
risky but I wanted to gamble yeah here
looking for me at least what I should do
and here so he can take j ya hear that
the changin gives a draw yet not too
surprising to me it could be am Bishop
before Wow didn't see that I mean you
have to just just go for it in such a
situation and hope it somehow summer
hols b5 was good now yeah he probably
has a ton ton of instead of the King on
B file is extremely irritating and our a
sixes are made check check check mate
yeah again there's a maid you know I can
take with the bishop actually I Carol I
have six seconds so I'm kind of okay
with 100 and I can take on g8 okay has
no time whatsoever and a ethics is a
chant again winning with Britain what
exactly yeah yeah just found out that
King is running all over the place like
this yes would will check at the end oh
my god yeah okay I was extremely lucky I
was yeah an unjust unwanted to gamble
their own my part ok guys thanks for
watching